[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo
ici au parlement européen à bruxelles
c'est le feuilleton qui tient l'europe
en haleine bien sûr nous allons évoquer
le bre exit nous allons parler des
différents scénarios qui circulent dans
la capitale européenne
nous ferons le point avec notre invité
gabriel grésillons le correspondant des
échos en charge du breakbeat et puis
dans la seconde partie d'europe hebdo on
restera au royaume-uni puisque nous
irons à londres voir comment fonctionne
le péage urbain avec nos invités
eurodéputés journaliste spécialiste des
transports nous nous demanderons de ce
que propose l'union européenne pour
réduire la pollution automobile
mais tout de suite un point donc sur les
derniers jours très compliqué de theresa
may la première ministre britannique
il n'y a toujours pas d'accord sur le
brésil regardez la date fatidique du 29
mars se rapproche inexorablement
et pourtant le royaume uni n'a toujours
pas choisi comment sortir de l'union
européenne mardi 15 janvier
l'accord présenté par theresa may a été
largement rejetée par les députés
britanniques a rappelé m
[Applaudissements]
avec entraîneur
encore un échec pour la première
ministre
les journaux titrent sur une défaite
historique
une humiliation complète le lendemain
mercredi 16 janvier
c'est une motion de défiance que theresa
may doit à présent affronter le leader
du parti travailliste jeremy corbyn
déclame sa tête des quatre caves à ce
gouvernement ne peut pas gouverner ils
n'arrivent pas à obtenir le soutien du
parlement sur la question la plus
importante à laquelle notre pays est
confronté
tous les premiers ministres précédents
dans cette situation aurait démissionné
et convoqué des élections une voix
seulement permettent à la chef des
conservateurs de rester aux commandes
elle appelle à une reprise du dialogue
avec l'opposition
je suis heureuse que cette chambre est
exprimé sa confiance envers le
gouvernement ce soir j'ai proposé une
série de rencontres entre les
parlementaires et des représentants du
gouvernement ou cours des prochains
jours
je voudrais inviter les dirigeants des
partis représentés ici à me rencontrer
individuellement et je souhaite lancer
ces rencontres dès ce soir
mais entre les briques zitter qui
veulent sortir de l'union sans accord et
les travaillistes qui ne veulent pas en
entendre parler
les marges de manoeuvre pour theresa may
sont étroites
un plan b elle n'en a pas vraiment
donc pour elle l'accord est la seule
alternative la meilleure façon d'écarter
la possibilité d'un odile elle que ce
parlement approuve un accord avec
l'union européenne
c'est ce que ce gouvernement cherche à
réaliser la seule autre façon d'éviter
un break 6 accor s'est de révoquer
l'article 50 ce qui signifierait restent
égaux dans l'union européenne
tout juste at elle pu annoncer la
suppression des frais de dossier pour
les ressortissants européens qui
souhaitent rester au royaume uni il faut
dire que les partenaires européens n'ont
pas franchement envie de re négocier à
neuf semaines et demie du brics est
alors pour comprendre à les différents
scénarios possibles j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir gabriel grésillons bonjour
bonjour vous êtes un des deux
correspondant des échos ici à bruxelles
et vous suivez ce feuilleton du brésil
quelle est l'ambiance au parlement
européen ces derniers jours écoutez à
bruxelles en général au parlement mais
aussi au conseil c'est à dire chez les
états membres c'est une ambiance très
particulière une ambiance d'attentes
d'inquiétude et je dirais aussi de
lassitude
quand même voir chez certains une forme
d'exaspération
alors ben on peut on peut balayer tous
ces éléments je pense que globalement
tout le monde se demande où va theresa
may et depuis le dernier sommet européen
de décembre il ya il ya une inquiétude
qui est assez forte parce qu'elle a
donné l'impression à ce moment là de ne
pas avoir véritablement de plans elle
implore régulièrement les européens lui
donner un peu plus mais on ne sait pas
exactement où elle veut aller
on en parle déjà depuis plusieurs
semaines mais le risque d'un audi
l'appareil de plus en plus grands
concrètement qu'est ce que ça signifie
s'il n'y a pas d'accord que se
passe-t-il le 29 mars prochain c'est
difficile de l'anticiper mais
globalement ça va ressembler un peu au
chaos d'une manière ou d'une autre alors
ce sera un chaos qu'on va réussir à à
limiter si on fait plein de petites
mesures sectorielles pour permettre
malgré tout quand même aux avions
d'atterrir et de décoller voilà donc on
peut trouver des moyens temporaires de
limiter la violence du choc mais pour
les 27 fin pour les européens il est
très clair qu'il faut absolument pas que
ces mini mesures sectorielles viennent
en fait faire disparaître les faits du
brésil donc leur vocation ce sera de
faire une transition en douceur de
quelques mois mais dans les faits on va
tout d'un coup se retrouver avec non
seulement peut-être des barrières
tarifaires mais toute une série de
problématiques de respect de règles et
donc en fait les flux de transfert de
marchandises pour ne parler que de ça il
ya bien d'autres aspects mais vont être
extrêmement compliqué donc ce serait je
pense que c'est quand même malgré tout
en dépit des postures c'est un scénario
que tout le monde cherche à éviter et
qui n'est pas si probable que ça pour
l'instant on voit et vous l'avez dit
theresa may essaye de rassurer dans son
pays qu'en disons qu'elle va retourner à
bruxelles essayé de négocier mais on a
l'impression pour l'union européenne il
ya plus de négociations michel barnier
un négociateur en chef le redit ce matin
il n'y a pas d'autres traités de divorce
possible le seul qui est sur la table
et bien c'est celui qu'on discute déjà
depuis plusieurs semaines on a parfois
le sentiment que ce qui est dit chez les
27 est assez mal compris là bas les
européens sont prêts à renégocier la
déclaration politique qui accompagne le
traité et qui elle
esquisse les grandes lignes de la
relation future mais pour ça il faudrait
qu'il y ait un signal britannique d'une
volonté de repenser cette relation
future dans une direction d'une plus
grande proximité voilà depuis le début
theresa may a dit mme bray xilinx
breakbeat et donc elle s'est positionnée
sur une ligne assez dur et je pense qu
elle en paye le prix aujourd'hui parce
que dans les faits pour toutes sortes de
raisons et notamment la question
irlandaise elle est obligée d'aller vers
une relation de relative proximité avec
les européens si elle se décider à
crever cet abcès et à dire ok je veux
une union douanière ou même soyons fous
resté très proche du marché unique
alors tout serait possible parce qu'on
pourrait repenser la déclaration
politique mais le traité lui-même il
faut quand même voir ce que c'est c'est
quasiment 600 pages c'est de l'exercice
âprement la a négocié âprement ses d'une
technicité inouïe en plus de notre côté
il ya 27 pays qui se sont mis d'accord
donc peut-être qu'il y aura trois bémols
qui vont modifier mes mails et pas plus
c'est sûr est ce que justement gabriel
chez ses 27 autres pays
on a le sentiment parfois que le royaume
uni veut un petit peu vulgairement le
beurre et l'argent du beurre c'est à
dire veut sortir mais en même temps
garder certains bénéfices est ce que
c'est ce qui se murmure dans les
couloirs à bruxelles en fait ça dépend
quand même des pays auxquels vous parlez
et des parlementaires auxquels vous
parler mais je crois que c'est un peu ça
la tonalité c'est quand même qu' il ya
beaucoup de pays qui contrairement à ce
qui peut se dire en france ont
énormément apprécié le rôle de l'union
europe le rôle par d'onde des royaumes
unis dans l'union européenne parce que
elle avait une vigilance sur sûr
rejeter le protectionnisme des choses
comme ça qu'on était très précieuse mais
aujourd'hui il ya un petit côté on en a
plus qu'assez de ce pays qui veut
effectivement le beurre et l'argent du
beurre et surtout ce que je disais tout
à l'heure qui s'obstine à ne pas vouloir
comprendre ou à faire semblant de ne pas
comprendre des choses qui pour nous pour
nous sont absolument claires et depuis
le début cette négociation c'est un peu
un dialogue de sourds
ici à une forme de fatigue moi je
parlais un diplomate du nord de l'europe
il ya trois jours le nord de l'europe
c'est souvent des pays qui sont assez
réceptifs à ce que représente le royaume
uni et qui me faisait part d'une forme
d'exaspération et qui me disait oui à la
limite le no deal et bien au moins ça
permettrait de clarifier les choses
parce que on a le sentiment que les
britanniques n'ont jamais véritablement
regarder ce problème en face justement
sur ce anodine donc le fait de quitter
l'union européenne sans accord qui est
le plus à perdre
on a l'impression l'union européenne
voit la menace un petit peu le royaume
uni mais ce que l'union européenne
pourrait aussi être perdante en cas de
nos deals c'est certain enfin personne
ne m'en là dessus ici tout le monde dit
le no deal c'est une catastrophe pour
tout le monde
simplement elle est quand même
asymétrique c'est-à-dire que le royaume
uni 44 % de ses exportations vont dans
l'union européenne 50 3% de ses
importations viennent de l'union
européenne donc en gros la moitié de ces
échanges c'est l'union européenne donc
évidemment que ce serait un drame pour
le royaume uni pour nous on peut
aucun pays ne peut dire le royaume uni
c'est 50% de mes échanges donc le choc
serait asymétrique
après ce qu'il faut voir c'est que il ya
la dimension économique la dimension
technique qui qui serait plus
problématique pour le royaume unique
pour nous après à la dimension
symbolique et politique et je crois que
pour l'union européenne
effectivement déboucher sur un odile ce
serait un constat d'échec à cette
terrible c'est à dire ne pas être
capable de rompre dans la sérénité avec
un pays aussi capitale non seulement au
plan économique mais encore plus au plan
stratégique
voilà un siège permanent au conseil de
sécurité l'arme atomique enfin un pays
est absolument clé dans le dispositif de
sécurité
ce serait quand même un terrible constat
d'échec dont je pense que là au plan eau
à long terme pour l'union européenne ce
serait vraiment pas brillant non plus
est-ce que l'éventualité d'un report on
parle de la date fatidique du 29 mars
est ce qu ici on se dit de toute façon
il faut reporter rien n'est prêt pour le
29 mars
il faut se donner encore un petit peu de
temps est ce que c'est une éventualité
qui circulent la wii alors ça circule
évidemment ça fait partie de tous et de
tous ces non dits dans ce dossier parce
qu'en fait tout le monde se rend bien
compte que ça simplifierait les choses
mais personne ne veulent envisager si
c'est pour redonner entre guillemets du
mou à une theresa may qui ne sait pas où
elle va
aujourd'hui il ya une vraie perception
que le le navire britannique et sans
capitaine ou en tout cas être à un
capitaine qui ne contrôle pas l'équipage
enfin vous prenez la métaphore que vous
voulez mais que dans les faits si on dit
aux britanniques tenez voilà six
semaines de plus pour quoi faire
donc les 27 ils veulent bien il faudrait
qu'à l'unanimité
il accepte cette prolongation mais ils
veulent une une demande en bonne et due
forme est justifié on veut prolonger
parce qu'on veut faire un deuxième
référendum par exemple ou parce que on
veut revenir négocier avec vous en
changeant nos lignes rouges parce qu'on
pense que l'union douanière finalement
ce serait une bonne solution
voilà s'il ya quelque chose de deux
structures et c'est envisageable avec
une remarque importante c'est qu'il ya
les élections européennes en mai et que
donc dans l'absolu il faudrait prolonger
de seulement quelques semaines
et si on doit envisager de prolonger au
delà c'est un casse tête juridique et
même ça pose des questions politiques
très très lourde d'envisager délire des
parlementaires britanniques pour une
période incertaine
voilà donc c'est quand même d'une
complexité inouïe merci beaucoup gabriel
région pour voir si cet éclairage vous
qui avez l'habitude donc des couloirs de
bruxelles
on reste au royaume uni pour réduire la
pollution liée à la voiture la capitale
londonienne fait payer ces conducteurs
avec un péage urbain
comment ça marche est ce que ça marche
en voiture tout avec françois dumoulin
[Musique]
c'est un péage qui porte mal son nom à
l'entrée de londres aucune barrière mais
un simple panneau ici commence
l'acompte geste une charge la taxe
embouteillages pour ceux qui n'auraient
pas vu le s'est inscrit sur le sol des
caméras scan leurs plaques
d'immatriculation et leur envoie une
amende directement à leur domicile par
in il est chef d'entreprise il livre des
ordinateurs dans le centre de la
capitale
il doit payer en ligne les 13 euros par
jour que coûte le péage j'étais votre
nom votre adresse
la plaque d'immatriculation c'est assez
simple et ensuite la prochaine étape
c'est votre numéro de carte bleue
en tant qu'entreprise ça me coûte entre
6000 et 11000 euros par an juste coût
rentrer et sortir de l'ombre et vous ne
pouvez rien y faire j'appelle ça de
l'argent mis à la poubelle vous
l'enlevez tout simplement de votre
chiffre d'affaires
pour éviter cette dépense jessica cadix
elle a choisi d'abandonner sa voiture
elle utilise désormais le métro est pour
elle les transports en commun de londres
n'ont pas été à la hauteur des enjeux
il y a des problèmes tous les jours dans
le métro il ya des lignes qui sont
connues pour être les pires du pays et
je pense qu'avec ça il n'encourage pas
les gens à laisser leur voiture au
garage
il faut payer jusqu'à 9 euros par jour
pour juste prendre le métro et la
plupart du temps les lignes sont
complètement bondé
même si certaines zones de la ville
reste paralysée par les bouchons le
trafic a diminué de 25% dans la capitale
depuis la création du péage en 2003 de
quoi satisfaire les grandes entreprises
qui perdent des millions d'euros chaque
année à cause des embouteillages
l'idéal serait un ph plus intelligent et
puissent cibler et quand les
embouteillages ont lieu dans la ville et
qui s'attaque vraiment à la pollution
un outil plus efficace peut-être que
cette taxe un peu brutale vivra pas la
même le ce et sorte de long on les aime
mais le principal échec de l'acompte
geste une charge concerne la pollution
elle est endémique à londres ici chaque
année près de dix mille personnes
meurent prématurément à cause des gaz
d'échappement le maire sadik-khan
lui-même asthmatique a créé en 2016 la
tite charge une autre taxe 10 euros par
jour pour les vieilles voitures d'avant
2006 plus polluantes
la mairie prévoit même d'aller plus loin
et d'étendre cette taxe d'ici 2021 à
toute l'agglomération
on veut encourager les gens à acheter
des véhicules plus propres
on met en place un réseau de bornes de
recharge pour les véhicules électriques
150 sont disponibles pour leur permettre
de recharger rapidement dans le centre
de londres
les londoniens sont donc appelés à se
mobiliser avec la main au portefeuille
d'autant que les aides publiques pour
acheter une voiture électrique ne
dépasse pas les 5000 euros en angleterre
d'ici 2021
un propriétaire de vieille voiture où
qu'ils soient dans londres devra payer
27 euros par jour pour se déplacer et un
vieux camion plus de 100 euros la
journée pour assurer sa livraison
voilà donc pour ce reportage à londres
de françois gaulle 1 et pour débattre de
la place de la voiture dans les
capitales européennes j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau dominique
riquet bonjour vous êtes député européen
français membre du groupe de l'alliance
des démocrates et des libéraux pour
l'europe
marc tarabella bonjour bonjour vous êtes
député européen belge vous appartenez
vous au groupe des socialistes et des
démocrates
et puis fans iront bonjour loi
journaliste pour le site contexte vous
êtes spécialiste des transports
dominique riquet faut-il instaurer à
l'entrée des villes ce type de péage
urbain pour limiter les voitures je
pense ça dépend du tort du moment et du
lieu et des villes croire le grand que
c'est un des moyens envisagés dans
certains cas mais ça peut pas être une
proposition au systématique chez vous
marc tarabella en belgique on essaye
aussi qu'il y ait le moins de voitures
possible dans les centres-villes et à
une réflexion sur le sujet il ya une
réflexion sur le sujet parce que tout
dépend des villes mais si on prend
l'exemple de bruxelles
cette réflexion se fait jour depuis un
certain temps parce qu'un engorgement de
la ville mais je dirais que cette
réflexion doit aller de pair aussi avec
le fait d'imaginer des investissements
qui vont aller de pair ils vont
permettre aux personnes qui n'ont
d'autre choix que de prendre leur
voiture parce que l insuffisance de
transport en commun par exemple ou une
insuffisance de train ou de tram
suffisamment fréquents et qui arrivent à
l'heure au bord des villes de manière à
ce que les automobilistes pour éviter
d'entrer en ville puisse laisser dans
les parkings gratuits à l'abri des
parkings couverts leur voiture
gardez la journée pour pouvoir rentrer
en vie les épaules des transports
efficient c'est loin d'être le cas
notamment à bruxelles aujourd'hui 2000
criquets à paris notamment c'est
l'éternel débat c'est tout un tas de
questions qu'il faut se poser avant de
mettre en place à une taxe pour entrer
dans la ville
ça dépend d'abord ce que vous cherchez
avec la taxe est ce que ces divisions et
la congestion division et la pollution
améliorer la circulation alors comme
marc tarabella viens de le dire il faut
aussi s'assurer que je n'ai pas que le
péage s'il ya des solutions alternatives
on proposait en transport en commun la
capacité de laisser sa voiture ou son
véhicule avant le péage des mobilités
différente des mobilités différentes
elles sont importantes et on voit bien
que ça dépend aussi de la nature david
parlait de bruxelles qui est une ville
extrêmement étendue avec un système de
concentration de navetteurs alors que
paris s'est dit très très dense donc les
sujets sont pas les mêmes pour voix très
adaptable fanny rouas vous vous suivez
la commission des transports
les péages urbains c'est pas à
proprement parler une compétence
européenne caler la réflexion du coup
sûr la pollution automobile
alors effectivement la commission
européenne n'a pas le droit d'imposer
aux états de mettre des péages urbains
de mettre en place des péages urbains
néanmoins la réflexion existe elle et
elle est présente dans beaucoup de
rapport mais comme un des outils
possibles comme disait monsieur riquet
juste avant pour réduire la pollution et
la congestion routière là où la
commission et les parlementaires peuvent
agir c'est plutôt sur la près les
conséquences c'est-à-dire la pollution
est là dessus
il ya beaucoup de législation en cours
sur le co2 des voitures les émissions de
co2 mais également ceux qui pêchent
vraiment ville les particules fines
le diesel pour revenir on va parler du
diesel mais sur le co2 - 37,5 %
d'émissions de co2 c'est ce que prévoit
l'union européenne en 2030 par rapport à
comment se passent les discussions entre
les pays est ce que c'était un compromis
qui a été facile à trouver monsieur eric
est très difficile parce que c'est à la
fois en fonction des pays et que vous
dites mais aussi pour tenir compte des
problèmes environnementaux mais aussi
des problèmes de de shift 2 d'adaptation
de l'industrie faut pas oublier que
trois millions de postes d'emploi dans
le sujet donc c'est vrai que si on donne
des normes qui sont extraordinairement
contraignante à l'industrie un risque de
pas pouvoir suivre mais en même temps si
on lui donne pas de norme elle va pas
non plus être concurrentiel de haut
niveau mondial
tarabella pour tout ce qui est voiture
justement on a le compromis à trouver
entre eux
la pollution a diminué l'industrie à
sauvegarder le consommateur aussi à
préserver
oui mais c'est très compliqué ceux ci on
parle effectivement des réductions de
co2 alors il faut encourager le diesel
comme on l'a fait en belgique pendant
plusieurs décennies maintenant on fait
exactement l'inversé on décourage disait
d'ailleurs il est surtaxé par rapport à
l'essence aujourd'hui mais le problème
c'est effectivement les particules fines
que vous l'avez mentionné un au sein des
villes
si on encourage le retour aux véhicules
à essence on va augmenter la quantité de
co2 donc il faut évidemment essayer
d'aller vers bien sûr les voitures
électriques les voitures partagées il ya
plusieurs sociétés qui se partagent le
marché à à bruxelles et dans d'autres
villes
c'est probablement la voiture du futur
qui sera aussi une solution de voiture
intelligente qui vont chercher là où
vous êtes qui va vous conduire là où
vous voulez aller et c'était quelqu'un
d'autre qui va la prendre à vous la
laissez pour aller vers ailleurs sans
doute tout cela doit faire l'objet plus
de réflexion d'action concerté mais il
faut toujours éviter me semble-t-il de
pénaliser le travailleur celui qui n'a
d'autre choix que d'aller en ville avec
sa voiture parce qu'il est livreur parce
qu'il est taxi parce qu'il est voyageur
de commerce et donc malheureusement on
ne taxe pas là où ça devrait on ne taxe
pas le
le fuel des bateaux hors un bateau de
dire à un navire de croisière ses hippo
lui comme un million de voitures on ne
taxe pas non plus le kérosène or les
voyages en avion se multiplient ils vont
doubler d'ici 2030 2036 je pense sur la
planète
il faut être cohérent et pas seulement
toujours tomber sur les pauvres
automobilistes qui doivent aller
travailler quotidiennement
dominique riquet ce que dit marc
tarabella ça fait terriblement écho à la
situation aussi en france avec les
gilets jaunes d'une taxe écologique qui
est ressenti par une partie de la
population comme vraiment une taxe
agressive
est ce que cette réflexion là aussi on
l'amène en europe justement
oui alors l'europe n'a pas de capacité
de réglementer les prélèvements les
taxes ou le fisc a en tout cas de
l'élève pas lève pas d'impôts mais moi
je crois que le problème le tour bilis
c'est plutôt l'accumulation des plaisirs
et pas seulement derrière des mesures
fiscales mais l'augmentation d'assises
sur les carburants mais les limitations
de vitesse
mais la roue le renforcement des
contrôles et m en amont bordeaux dé la
bête se rebelle finir on en revient à un
petit pas est ce qui se passe ici à
bruxelles au sein de la commission des
transports sa présidente karima delli
dit qu'effectivement dès qu'on parle de
la voiture le lobby automobile est très
important freinent comment ça se passe
concrètement alors elle n'est pas la
seule à le dire sur tous les dossiers
qui touchent le diesel les émissions co2
de nombreux députés de différents partis
qui m'ont fait part de leurs parfois
agacement de recevoir trop de mails etc
donc c'est une réalité donc les lobbys
sont là ils sont là de manière
différente vous avez de nombreuses
fédérations nationales européennes à
bruxelles
vous avez aussi
les constructeurs tous les constructeurs
donc ils sont là et moi ce que j'ai
observé c'est plutôt un lobbying
protéiforme c'est-à-dire un mobile
classique de couloir on va ce qui est
assez classique normal on va défendre un
argumentaire on va parfois jusqu'à
préparer des amendements mais aussi on
va être sur le plan de la communication
on va publier la veille des votes des
des études
voilà une guerre des études entre ong
constructeur qui convergent très
rarement qu'on peut observer
quant à leur poids il faut ne faut pas
oublier que ils sont aussi dans les
capitales et ça c'est très important de
le dire
prenez paris berlin les lobbys sont là
aussi et même à paris même dans la ville
de paris souvenez vous quand anne
hidalgo se plaignait des menaces du
secteur donc c'est oui ils sont à
bruxelles mais c'est m ils sont aussi
dans tous les lieux de pouvoir européen
c'est une réalité au quotidien marc
tarabella lobby est une réalité moi j'ai
rencontre peu parce que je ne suis pas
membre de la commission transports qui
est compétente au fond mais
effectivement dans d'autres matières les
lobbys sont présents il faut juste
apprendre pour être une source
d'informations moi c'est comme ça moi je
rends compte tout le monde qui veut me
voir c'est un grand précédent ma vie
politique au niveau local au niveau
européen pourquoi parce que ça respecte
ceux qui travaillent ça vous permet
d'avoir gelé propres de sources
d'informations à moi de la décoder et à
moi de tracer ma ligne je suis toujours
procéder comme cela et j'estime que on
doit écouter on n'est pas obligé de
suivre un degré de liberté il ya quand
même fondamental ici mais ils agissent
effectivement mais souvent en prenant
rendez vous moi je n'aime pas lobbying
de couloir je les évite
ils doivent prendre rendez vous doivent
arriver à l'heure et ça dure une
demi-heure maximum grands pas si
dominique riquet vous créez vice
président de la commission des
transports quand on légifère sur les
voitures on sent que c'est un sujet
sensible
quand mon roman parce qu'à vous avez
l'un du cycle est une des plus
importantes en europe dans des emplois
etc des familles et deuxièmement qui ne
dépend pas toutes parties sa voiture
avant donc en l'occurrence fictivement
faut être extrêmement prudent le sujet
chaud reçoit du lobby et des lobbys
du du secteur automobile industrielles
mais on reçoit aussi des organisations
non gouvernementales les associations de
consommateurs les protections de des
citoyens et comme le disait mark j il
suffit de recevoir bannière équilibrait
de manière régler est de savoir qui
parle qui parle évidemment je sais bien
que si je reçois les constructeurs
automobiles vont pas me dire exactement
le même discours que si je reçois une
organisation non gouvernementale
protection de l'environnement et finir
ou comment ça se passe au niveau du
rapport de forces est ce que les pays
nationaux veulent aller plus loin est ce
que c'est l'europe qui freine un peu
dont la pollution automobile comment ça
se passe alors c'est ses nuances et en
fonction des textes en fonction
est ce qu'on parle du diesel est ce
qu'on parle du co2 parce qu'il ya des
textes différents
ce que je peux dire c'est que la france
parce que c'est elle se montre
volontariste dans le point de vue de la
communication dans les faits au sein du
conseil de l'ue c'est plus compliqué il
faut faire des compromis notamment avec
l'allemagne qui n'est pas qu'ils ne
figurent pas du tout parmi les nations
les plus ambitieuses
car elle défend corps et âme son
industrie automobile telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui et donc dans les textes des
précédentes semaines sur le co2 des
voitures sur le co2 des camions la
france a dû ménager la chèvre et le chou
avec son partenaire allemand
dominique riquet c'est l'allemagne avec
qui c'est le plus compliqué la
négociation premières industries en aval
c'est l'automobile ça lobby extrêmement
puissants mais ils ont aussi des lobbys
environnementalistes qui sont très
puissants en réalité en général c'est la
commission propose des taux le parlement
avait lieu entre lui seront plus
exigeants et le conseil essaye de
revenir en bas parce que le principe le
conseil secure général or on va vers le
niveau le bois de moins exigeant c'est
celui qui était le plus bas j'ai
simplement dire une chose c'est qu'il ya
aussi une différence
entre les pays pour deux raisons
premièrement parce que plus vous allez à
l'est pour des raisons climatologiques
puis vous êtes polluer en termes de
qualité de l'air à dépendamment des
émissions et la deuxième chose c'est que
les voitures polluantes de deuxième aux
biens génération de l'ouest sont vendus
à l'est l'année dernière 400 mille
véhicules diesel de type 2 qui ont été
vendus d'allemagne en pologne et la
belgique dans tout ça marc tarabella
assez volontariste les volontaristes
mais je peux regretter le manque de
considération je le répète qu'on a
aujourd'hui pour les automobilistes qui
n'ont d'autre choix que de prendre des
voix que moi j'en ai lu rural est donc
prêt à évidemment désengorger les villes
il le faut c'est une nécessité
on va de par le fait que soient
parlementaires dominique riquet et moi
nous allons à strasbourg une fois par
mois en plénière
pendant trois jours c'est une ville qui
respire strasbourg mais hormis un
courage il ya vingt ans de faire un tram
efficace et qui fait que à désengorger
la ville mais attention à ne pas
pénaliser je le répète ceux qui n'ont
d'autre choix et de prendre leur voiture
parce que les transports en commun ne
sont pas encore à la hauteur de ce qui
devrait être
eh bien ce sera le mot de la fin merci
beaucoup marc tarabella merci fagnot et
merci dominique riquet d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission sur nos
sites internet
lcp public sénat et la rtbf très belle
semaine à tous
[Musique]